[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
seems only appropriate to have a legend
like david bowie bring us back from
commercial break we're going to talk
some music memorabilia with the colts
owner jim irsay
he's got a lot of stuff a lot of guitars
just bought a piano that was elton
john's john lennon's piano
bring in the uh colts owner jimmer say
uh jim thanks for joining us we'll we'll
get to uh carson wentz we'll get to
peyton manning we'll get to andrew luck
but uh what's what's the piece of
memorabilia that you don't have what you
want
well it's a great question and i'm
reading i've read several books about it
uh
i'm reading one now actually
um i believe the holy grail from
my perspective as an artist as a
collector as a musician as
whatever term you want to use
a human traveler uh
is robert johnson's guitar
it probably won't ever be found his
guitar you know if you talk to musicians
like you're a clapton
um
you know p towns and just the great
greatest guitarist ever
you know robert johnson um
you just developed a style of play
that um it influenced people today and
and um is is probably the most iconic
musician that kind of combines
all forms of music so i'd love to find
it but i don't think we will but that's
why it's the holy grail but you buy
elton john's steinway
do you play it or just look at it
that one is is very much of a playable
um incredible steinway um
i have um
john lennon's piano
and
it was in his
flat in his house for many many years he
wrote sergeant peppers on it um he put a
plaque on it on the side and listed some
of the songs he wrote on it um
and quietly
somehow
um i secured it in a sale um
except that when it came
it was never taken care of very much
since don passed away 40 years ago so
um so it doesn't really play
uh there's some dead keys um on it uh so
the debate goes on with things like that
do you fix it or do you leave it as he
left it
what do you remember about that day i
think you were 12 years of age when your
dad purchased the colts was that 1971
you were 12.
yeah i i was um
uh i was 12 years old
and the biggest thing that i remember
is we went up to training camp at golden
colorado where they make the coors beer
you know back then you used to go on the
road for training camps and they like
the altitude
so i'm 12 years old
i'm nervous
as hal i'm in the cafeteria
it's training camp i'm there to work as
a ball boy and i get a tap on my
shoulder and it's
sun
move your ass and it was johnny and
knight
so i'm like yes sir you know and i sat
down and that began the lineage of um
all the players telling me
what i how i needed to do things when my
time came i had the 75 team in 2012 and
bert jones and everyone was still alive
you know ray oldham was gone and we
couldn't find
jackie wallace unfortunately nelson
muncie was gone but besides that bert
jones lido mitchell ray chester
george coons ted marshall broda they all
came in i gave them division
championship rings from 75 and i sent
one to bill balanche because see bill
was i was here's this
16 year old the funny thing about the
flake gate was here's this 16 year old
kid okay my responsibility was
put the vaseline on the offensive
lineman but they're yelling at you wipe
it down because it's got to look like
sweat because it's not legal you know so
they have tight jerseys so the defensive
lineman can't grab the offensive lineman
so they're yelling at me you know these
giants wipe it down you know so you know
because they they knew we were artists
on how to make it look like sweat so you
know six feet away you know bill
belichick sitting there you know 24
years old as teddy's only 10 martial
bros only intern coach that you're
watching me do this you know when
deflate gate came up i just can only
laugh because you know here's bill here
am i in a different year in our lives
you know but i i did send bill a ring
for that i actually saw bill at the hall
of fame this weekend so that was fun did
you think about trying to put an end to
deflategate because it it really didn't
impact anything i mean it was kind of
silly
you know um
it it kind of got got legs of it of its
own you know um i i don't really think
it um
you know has any merit to anyone's
legacy
you know upping their legacy or damaging
it at all of course not at all i i just
um
um i think it's just one of those things
where you know
you know dan we're competitors and damn
it
if you want to fight
i mean you know the patriots and cults
you have to remember i mean brother i
mean it's like you know we love each
other off the field we really do i mean
i saw tom brady i saw tom up there i saw
bill
i love those guys i have the utmost
respect for him but when we're in the
ring
you know hey it's give no quarter take
no quarter i have a piece of memorabilia
here
one of a kind
and i don't know if you would have been
interested in this but i have ryan
leaf's jersey
if the colts had drafted
ryan leaf
so they shot a little commercial promo
and he held up the colts jersey so ryan
gave me the jersey autographed the
jersey but then i found out the uh the
great rolling stone writer hunter s
thompson
wrote you a letter prior to the 1998
draft and said select ryan leap do you
still have that letter
i do i i still have it
hunter was just so
hilarious you know um that would have
been the reason why i wouldn't have
drafted ryan leaf if hunter thompson is
telling me to draft ryan lee
well it's really interesting you know
some of these things have popped up and
i'm so proud of ryan to see him doing so
well i saw him you know i have a picture
of peyton and i and him uh at the hall
of fame
um you know on friday night before we
did the gold jackets and and he was just
there and peyton invited him to sit down
at his table which i thought was awesome
and uh you know i was just talking to
ryan and then you know um ryan's been
kind of you know doing i know some
broadcast work and stuff and uh um
you know it's quite the story it really
is i i can only tell you that
half the national football league would
have taken ryan leaf and half would have
taken peyton if anyone says different
they're not telling the truth uh
you know i i had a trusted trusted
personnel person that i knew you know
for decades that was very expert
you know and five minutes before the
draft i said who are you taking and he
said ryan leaked i mean this guy's good
you know and and
and he was wrong you know but um
we we try to be as right as we can but
but you just
you know i mean the thing about bill
paulian is um you know
i brought him in so him and i could
huddle up on a decision like that speech
almost sounded like an audition
for being the commissioner
well i don't think he has to audition
for almost anything quite frankly you
know i i think it's like president
united states commissioner
you know own an nfl team let's see which
one um
knowing peyton i i'm not sure what
direction you know him and i have had a
lot of talks and and and we've talked
through the years and talked through
some scenarios uh since he's retired and
and that sort of thing
but um i think he's done the right thing
you know john elway took a long time
before he jumped back in it and
and payton has been retired only for a
certain amount of time and he has young
kids still
um but i i really think with peyton that
he's a competitor
and
the thing he likes to do the most is win
football games you know he wants to beat
you
and be part of professional football on
a team
you know i i think he would like to to
go uh
win a lot of games
as a owner slash general manager
whatever you want to call
have
it
talked about him coming in part of the
ownership of the colts
i uh not not on ownership you know that
wouldn't be available here
um it's just something you know when you
own 100 like i do
um and my family does and you're going
down that lineage line i mean i i
look at you know i i think
most of us owners like the rooney's and
the mirrors and the houses you know we
would never give up a percentage of our
team we just wouldn't it's just i guess
old school you know the hunts or
whatever well when's the last time
somebody made an offer to buy the colts
recently you know probably about about a
uh a job probably
you know
um
probably about a month ago to be honest
with you you know uh
it's a great
look it's a great investment i've told
any owner that's ever come into the
league and i've talked to a lot of them
i said
you know you will never regret what you
just paid for this club it will be worth
more than you can imagine and you will
never look back because in the 100 year
history of the league no one has no one
has ever not once you know and um those
things you know look at those things can
disappear you never get um
you know uh overconfident because uh um
the largest
mountain can fall when's the last time
you talked to andrew luck
well gosh i say it's been probably about
um
you know probably about
at least a year you know um
i i mean in my mind
when when this thing ended
um
it wasn't coming back you know it just
and i talked to chris and frank about it
and
and you know i i know they were really
you know hoping that it would come back
um other people
thought maybe uh time would would change
something
but i really knew deep down inside of me
that that that it was that it was over
you know that that um
that it wasn't coming back and and and
he wasn't coming back and i think
um
before i tell you it's something you
know to be a franchise quarterback in
this league you can't be in 95
i mean you've got to be in 100
i i mean it is
it is big time demanding you know and
and um so
um i just wish him well um with his
daughter and and he has a wonderful wife
and and he has a a big future ahead of
them it's just not
you know in in
professional football as a quarterback
and and he's made that clear
um and he's never wavered on that are
you expecting carson wentz to be your
starting quarterback that opening game
against seattle
you know i i hope that he is but i told
carson i said hey
you got to be 100 before you come back
none of us want you to rush it you know
we want to look back two years from now
four years from now six years from now
and say
this is you know his 101st consecutive
start or whatever um
that that's what it's about my
biggest goal
to do anything i possibly could
you know is is to give the best
atmosphere for him
to stay healthy and stay in the field
because you know he's a tough guy and he
wants it he wants that as much as anyone
um and i think it's just a question of
getting in into that that that you know
the football gods call what you want but
just into that groove i mean obviously
you know he's a he's a big strong guy
he's a competitor he's a tough guy he's
everything that you're looking for and i
don't think there's a question
he'll fail if he stays healthy and stays
on the field no question in my mind
he will be a top five or six quarterback
it's great to catch up with you again
jim i hope you're healthy and uh good
luck with this upcoming season
well thanks so much we love watching you
and thank you for having me that's jim
irsay the colts owner